[Música]
no están buenos días
pueden las redes sociales transformar
nuestro entorno y transformar la
sociedad yo creo que depende de nosotros
del uso que nosotros les demos levanten
la mano tiene aquí usa facebook
casi todos quien usa twitter
porque también los interés siempre
vídeos en youtube la mayoría estamos
inmersos en el mundo de las redes
sociales ya no es algo que se queda
fuera de nuestra vida educación
tecnología y redes sociales son
conceptos que están estrechamente
vinculados y otra vez en las redes
sociales de la universidad de su
universidad estaba observando con
atención que este espacio este recinto
hace apenas unos días lucía de esta
manera y alguien con su imaginación
diseñó unas paredes precisamente
atendiendo a lo que decían mis
compañeros en las charlas anteriores a
dejar menos daño al medio ambiente y con
unas cajas de cartón crearon todo un
escenario diferente transformar nuestro
entorno con imaginación es una
innovación y que están en las manos de
cualquiera de ustedes
pero ahora vamos a enfocar a la parte de
las redes sociales cómo vamos a hacer
esa transformación desde un teléfono
celular o desde nuestra computadora
vamos a ver que la mayoría de los que
levantó la mano seguramente sabrán que
la mayoría de los posts tiene que ver
con el fis tiene que ver con viajes y
tiene que ver con comidas
seguramente bueno en otras universidades
aquí no ha pasado seguramente han visto
algunas personas que suben unas elsa y
de repente
en la parte de atrás está toda llena de
ropa sucia y está aquí no verdad
aquí no sucedió pero otro así entonces
no cuidamos el entorno que nos rodea
debemos de cuidarnos y acuérdense que
hay un hada una como regla entre más
arriba el teléfono más qué
y debemos ser muy cuidadosos a la hora
de publicar pero qué sucede si estas
publicaciones van un poquito más allá de
únicamente compartir nuestra vida dice
un amigo octavio regalado que el
facebook es la nueva telenovela estamos
pendientes de lo que sucede con la vida
de los demás todos nos centramos por
redes sociales sí pero qué pasa si yo
soy una fotografía de comida yo lo que
espero no nada más es compartir lo que
me comí que me comienzos camarón los
religiosos no si no si quieren un
poquitito más allá yo voy a decir lo
compré aquí en este restaurante o hay
una señora que vende tan malditos en
esta esquina y ya estoy apoyando la
economía de mí de mí de mi ciudad o del
lugar en donde yo estoy visitando
quiero contarles y quiero que nos
vayamos a 2009 hace 10 años cuando yo
empecé con el mundo del twitter y las
redes sociales te preparaba para ir a
trabajar como todos los días yo soy
maestra prendí la televisión para poder
estar escuchando las noticias en lo que
me preparaba y entonces me encontré una
entrevista con josé hernández que es un
astronauta mexicano oriundo de michoacán
su familia es migrante y actualmente
está en ciudad de cádiz o están en el
estado de california eeuu cuando yo vi
la entrevista fue algo que me marcó para
toda la vida porque él decía que le
gustaría que todos los mandatarios del
mundo tuvieran la oportunidad de verla
en la tierra que de ver nuestro planeta
desde donde él la estaba viendo esta
misión la misión sts-128 orbitó durante
13 días en estar en este espacio es
estación espacial internacional y en la
entrevista el comentaba
lo que estaba viendo es que no había
fronteras tal y como nosotros las
aprendimos ustedes recordarán que en la
primaria nos enseñan que en el mapa el
país termina aquí y de aquí para allá ya
es otro país ya son otras costumbres ya
son otras leyes y demás pero qué pasa
cuando nos cambian la perspectiva y
entonces nos damos cuenta que esas
fronteras únicamente las trazamos
nosotros por cuestiones de poder y
empezamos a delimitar todo no me puedo
salir de aquí sí
qué pasa si nosotros transformamos eso
en beneficios para toda mi comunidad
cuando yo observé la entrevista de josé
hernández es decía que publicaba en
tiempo real fotografías de lo que estaba
pasando allá arriba y publicaba vídeos
publicaban mensajes en español fue el
primer astronauta en público en tuitear
en español éramos miles y millones de
personas en el mundo pendientes de lo
que sucedía en el espacio yo era una de
los miles de miles de personas y empecé
a mirar mucho el trabajo de jose
hernandez
entonces sucedió algo muy curioso abrí
mi cuenta de twitter quería saber que
era la desconocida completamente cómo
funcionaba esta red social y entonces
busqué los comentarios del astronauta
mexicano los encontré en 2014 sucedió
algo que yo así me quedé sorprendido y
sima hasta ahora madura además está hoy
madura de emoción
jose hernandez te estás siguiendo a mí a
mí y yo yo yo yo admiro pero yo no
estaba viendo en la televisión y él
estaba allá en el espacio y me está
siguiendo a mí seguramente algo estoy
diciendo bien en mis redes sociales
hicimos contacto y me invitó a que lo
conocieran una conferencia no pude
asistir fui después quedamos a cenar en
conocido restaurante del paseo de la
reforma en mexico y cuando yo esperaba
el astronauta decía esto no me puede
estar pasando a mí no no es cierto
cuando de repente lo voy a pasar entro
estuvimos platicando es una persona muy
muy muy sencilla y cuando lo tuve de
frente entendí el poder enorme que
tienen las redes sociales uno
puede llegar a conocer a personas que
para nosotros tengan una importancia
desde el ámbito laboral o desde el
ámbito personal pues ya conocieron a
hugo lezama verdad sí y también yo lo
conocí a través de redes sociales viendo
su trabajo podemos nosotros llegar a
quien nosotros queramos pero depende de
cómo nos comportemos en las redes
tenemos por aquí la foto porque cuando
me ha tocado contar que es que yo conocí
a través de twitter a nuestro nauta de
verdad alguien te creería suena como muy
fantasioso no pues se descose hernández
y pues él es el que ha inspirado el
trabajo que yo he hecho en redes
sociales pero así como me han pasado
cosas positivas así también he tenido
experiencias muy negativas que
lamentablemente me han lastimado como
persona y han lastimado a mi familia
tuve una dinámica que establecí a través
de twitter y muchas personas contactaron
conmigo una de ellas era un muchacho
bastante amable bastante educado porque
no bastante guapo y empezamos a tener
una relación de amistad
él me presento a su prima me presento a
su primo a su sobrino a infinidad de
personas de su familia a su papá de
todas las redes sociales establecí una
amistad también con la prima este es que
es con la que yo tenía contacto de
manera física y pasaron más de seis
meses en lo que yo me di cuenta fue lo
que me tardé en darme cuenta de que el
primo el primo el sobrino la mamá el
papá todos ellos eran perfiles falsos
que había creado una sola persona si yo
creía que al llevar tanto tiempo en el
mundo de las redes sociales era experta
en eso y esta persona me vino a
demostrar que yo no era experta en nada
que cualquier persona nos puede engañar
que cualquier persona nos puede sacar
dinero que cualquier persona nos puede
lastimar y que en cualquier momento
estamos en riesgo si no somos cuidadosos
me costó una depresión tremenda mis
amigos se rieron mucho
se reían y eso me ayudó mucho porque lo
vieron desde la parte divertida y eso me
ayudó a superar el que haya estado a
vida y perdón que haya sido engañada
durante tanto tiempo pero nunca vamos a
saber cuál es la experiencia que va a
definir el resto de nuestra vida y con
cuál experiencia me quedo para crecer
después te tienes que volver muy
cuidadoso de lo que sucede en nuestro
entorno de las redes sociales porque
puede ser que tenga una experiencia
exitosa y puede ser que tenga una
experiencia desastrosa
las redes sociales son una herramienta
muy muy muy poderosa que si la tenemos
en las manos y la sabemos explotar puede
derivar en cosas mal está mente
positivas en el caso mío que soy maestra
les comentaba dije bueno y cómo puedo
utilizar las redes sociales para educar
porque eso es todo un reto te tienes que
imaginar qué haces con el twitter o qué
haces con el facebook si todo está
metido ahí dices y todos lo tienen pues
yo quiero que tenga algo de la educación
que te que tenga algo que ver con mi
ámbito laboral entonces la primera cosa
que hice fue tratar de resolver un
problema de mi comunidad y por eso
tratando de resolver el problema con el
que lidiamos todos los días el tráfico
las manifestaciones los bloqueos diseñé
este proyecto que se llama habilidad
xalapa a través de él yo trato de
informar a la sociedad de qué es lo que
está sucediendo en tiempo real quería yo
crear una comunidad tan grande que todo
el mundo demandará sus reportes y que si
yo no tengo la capacidad de estar en
todo
la ciudad las demás personas y los demás
usuarios compartan también de esa manera
altruista para que para que yo me evite
un embotellamiento para que yo pueda
resolver cuestiones como que se necesita
sangre que si alguien perdió una mascota
que si alguien quiere la receta de la
biblia que si alguien quiere quedar en
una alberca y quiere saber en donde
contactan a un prestador de servicios
todo eso empezó a impactar en la
sociedad llegó un momento en el que las
autoridades voltearon a ver a la cuenta
ciudadana y entonces empezamos a
trabajar en conjunto yo sola no tengo la
capacidad de que si alguien me dice es
que tengo una fuga de agua en mi casa yo
no voy a ir con una con un pico y con
una pala arreglar toda la fuga de agua
pero si puedo ser el enlace con las
autoridades correspondientes y ellos son
las que lo arreglan y entonces a través
de un celular a través de un dispositivo
móvil yo ya estoy resolviendo la
necesidad de alguien que no conozco pero
que sé que vale tanto
o cualquiera de los que estamos en una
ciudad ahora en el ámbito laboral
también dije quiero desarrollar un
proyecto para mis alumnos y entonces
empecé a dar clases por youtube a mandar
vídeo
grabar vídeos de lo que hacíamos en
clases porque yo tengo muchos alumnos
que son hijos de mi grandes y que sus
papás están en los eeuu y que no pueden
venir a las juntas de trabajo pero
quieren estar pendiente de lo que
estamos haciendo cuando grabo estos
vídeos y los subí a youtube los papás
que estaban allá en otro país podían ver
que estaban haciendo sus chicos sí
entonces dices estamos acortando las
distancias estamos llevando a la
educación un poquito más allá y aparte
utilizamos el blog de aula los niños les
gusta ver a la maestra en las redes les
gusta verla en los vídeos les gusta que
les cuentes cuentos a través de youtube
y ya estamos haciendo un uso de las
redes que no nada más es postear mi vida
y ya sino que le puede servir a alguien
más ustedes que están estudiando
sea cual sea la carrera que vayan a
escoger pueden llegar a las redes
sociales y se pueden convertir en un
fenómeno de este vial pueden convertir
la idea que ustedes tengan cualquiera
que sea está en algo exitoso pero va a
depender de ustedes y de su
responsabilidad pero ojo cuando vayan a
emprender un proyecto yo me lleve muchos
años en entenderlo y hoy se los quiero
decir muy rápido hay una huella digital
que nosotros vamos dejando que es todas
las actividades que hagamos a través de
la red se va quedando registrada ya por
ahí vimos el vídeo de las cookies y todo
eso todo lo que ustedes busquen se queda
esta huella es voluntaria o involuntaria
ustedes llegan registro de todo lo que
postean si la lista de los novios este a
donde fui con quien estuve todo eso lo
hacemos de manera voluntaria pero de
manera involuntarios cuando yo me meto a
un buscador a buscar algo que a lo mejor
no quiero que los demás se enteren pero
todo queda registrado y debemos de ser
cuidadosos
esta huella perdura el tiempo aunque
ustedes digan ay sube una foto más
facebook que lo mejor en bikini pero ya
me arrepentí la voy a borrar pero en ese
momento en que estuvo arriba de la red
cualquiera cualquiera con malas
intenciones puede imprimir pantalla la
guarda y se queda ahí para siempre y no
hay nada que puedan hacer para que eso
desaparezca y también a terceras
personas es cierto que las plataformas
tienen medidas de seguridad pero sabemos
que la realidad no hay forma en la que
podamos tener el control completo de
nuestra privacidad así que debemos de
ser muy cuidadosos con lo que posteamos
por qué por qué sucede esto un post
trasciende fronteras cuando yo publico y
me quejo de mi trabajo que no me gusta
como me trata mi jefe o que de cualquier
cosa de repente llegamos y lo publicamos
yo muchas veces les he dicho si
posteamos algo que tiene que ver con el
ambiente laboral
pero podemos perder hasta nuestros
trabajos no me han creído muchas veces
pero ahora tenemos la experiencia de que
vivimos hace tres semanas seguramente
ustedes habrán estado enterados de que
una foto de conocida línea línea
mexicana hizo una publicación en el
facebook y esta publicación que para
ella se iba a quedar ahí nada más que
sucedió se volvió tuvo relevancia
nacional y hasta internacional puso en
riesgo su trabajo se tuvo que disculpar
la aerolínea tuvo que dar la cara por la
este por las acciones que había cometido
la piloto y no nada más la piloto al
otro piloto le contesta algo y solamente
con el simple hecho de contestar o de
poner un jajaja o de probar un retweet
en twitter ya con eso nos estamos
haciendo como partícipes de lo que dijo
una persona y entonces ponemos en riesgo
toda nuestra carrera únicamente porque
quise poner una broma no debían hacer
no debiera ser porque no debieran pero
ya mucha gente antes de contratarlos a
cada uno de ustedes revisa sus redes
sociales incluso para si ustedes quieren
solicitar una visa a los eeuu ya el
gobierno de los eeuu éste le solicita
que les que ustedes registran cuáles son
sus redes sociales y entonces que nos
vamos a encontrar no es para asustarlos
para nada ustedes sigan las utilizando
pero tenemos que trabajar con los
valores también dentro de las redes
sociales
si ustedes redes sociales de forma
positiva ustedes pueden lograr lo que
quieran en la cuenta de vialidad cada
pan tengo todos los días tengo que
contactar con más de 100 mil personas
que están observando me que están viendo
que público que digo que hago y no se
trata nada más de decir a ellos que
tiene muchos seguidores guau es súper
famosa así mirada a la regla de olvido
del meteorito etcétera no si tenemos
responsabilidad lo que se tiene en las
manos es una enorme responsabilidad
social no se trata de ser famoso por ser
famoso hay mucho contenido en internet
que regularmente no aporta nada entonces
tratemos de que si vamos a meternos en
este mundo de las redes tratemos de
aportarle algo al mundo
somos lo que publicamos si es una
extensión las redes sociales son una
extensión de nosotros y por ahí dicen
siempre hay un tweet también tenemos que
ser muy congruentes entre lo que decimos
y lo que hacemos a lo mejor hoy tengo
una ideología y dentro de seis años
tengo otra pero que creen se queda el
registro y ese pantallazo de lo que dije
y a lo mejor hoy estoy a favor de algo y
mañana no pero alguien siempre me lo va
a recordar porque porque les decía eso
permanecen ahora cuando yo público
siempre voy a dar a entender qué tipo de
persona soy si soy una persona
respetuosa como me dirijo a los demás en
las redes sociales debemos publicar con
responsabilidad ustedes sabían que
pueden matar a alguien simplemente con
el hecho de poner una coma mal
está como increíble no vamos a imaginar
que alguien un conocido de ustedes tuvo
un accidente leve un accidente leve
prólogo como no nos enteramos ya saben
que en facebook sucede de todo no y
alguien publican
qué pasó alguien pone qué pasó el
primero responde no se murió punto 5 ahí
ya no pasa nada no se murió pero otro a
lo mejor un despistado contesta no sé
cómo murió imagínense el impacto que
tiene esto en la primera frase se muere
o no se muere
y en la segunda
si se nos muere de verdad imagínense que
veamos algo y cuando si alguien es un
familiar y de repente ve eso hasta se
puede infectar el otro por el susto
porque vio en las redes sociales que ya
se le murió el hijo o el no sea el
pariente del esposo entonces ese pequeño
detalle cambia todo
vamos a ver otro ejemplo vamos a
imaginar ahora que ustedes demandando un
watts a su jefe oa su maestro porque va
a tener una participación en el tema
y de ponente desea mucho éxito a post
gracias no pero aquí sucede si le
ponemos te deseo mucho como éxito
ya cambia la causa
viendo estos temblando porque ya hasta
se declararon en el whatsapp cuando en
realidad no no era por ahí la idea
entonces vamos a hacer muy
cuidadosos responsables
conclusión inspira todo lo que hayan
traten de que inspire a los demás por
allí dice no te preocupes si alguien
copia tus ideas no se trata de copiar si
yo hago algo que inspira a alguien más
qué bueno qué bueno que mi trabajo le
sirvió a alguien mientras los demás
están desarrollando una idea a lo mejor
ustedes ya lo están consolidados
consolidando ya la perfeccionaron y ya
están trabajando en otra la innovación
se trata de eso de ir un paso adelante
de quienes apenas están trabajando pero
acuérdense que se trata de compartir si
yo tengo una buena idea y me funcionó
vengo y se las explicó no me la quedo y
digo así es que yo ya lo logré y los
demás a ver que hagan de cómo puedan no
compartan compartan y si alguien les
pide ayuda a ayudarlos si trabajan con
otras personas crean no tengan miedo de
crear y de poner un proyecto en marcha
cuando inicie realidad cada para en 2011
yo no sabía la trascendencia de esta
idea
años después me ha llevado por muchos
lados precisamente porque fue una idea
que pude desarrollar y queda fui
perfeccionando cuando empecé no empecé
como no empecé haciendo lo que ahora
hago en el camino vamos a tener nuevas
ideas vamos a tener aportaciones y
tenemos que estar atentos a lo que nos
dicen los demás para poder perfeccionar
nuestro propio trabajo equivocarte desde
el permiso de equivocarse me sale mal no
pasa nada aprendí para la otra ya no lo
voy a volver a hacer perdonen si no pasa
nada de verdad lo único que puedas es
que crezcan en experiencia y en redes
sociales algo es muy importante
disculpen sé si es cometieron un error
en redes sociales no tratan de borrarlo
no lo borren disculpen sé por qué eso
hablar bien de ustedes y finalmente
estudia no se trata únicamente de ella
abre un canal de youtube y este ahora me
voy a abandonar a la escuela a los 16
años como conocida youtuber no se trata
de eso seguramente le recordaron por
y ver si sabemos a quién estamos
hablando pero vamos a tratar de
mantenernos siempre a la vanguardia
porque porque hay gente que nos va a
estar leyendo actualmente yo estoy
estudiando un doctorado pero que creen
nos damos cuenta que entre más esas
estudiamos más ignoramos cosas queremos
saber más entonces sigan estudiando
aprovechen la oportunidad que no tiene
mucha gente educación superior es un
porcentaje muy pequeñito de mexicanos el
que tiene la oportunidad como ustedes y
jóvenes nunca dejen de estudiar gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]